if you use your credit cards you do not
want to be rich anytime you say
something about that people send it to
me
vice versa yeah so cut up your credit
cards if you use a credit card you don't
want to be rich yep I like that line
that's a good one that's my favorite
line I tell people all the time people
then they ask me well where's the best
place to invest I said your best place
to invest is to pay off all your credit
cards and burn them because your credit
card you know what your return is right
if you get off you know you're paying 15
20 interest if you pay that down you
just earn 15 or 20 percent folks I've
told you 100 times and uh Forbes 400 400
wealthiest people in North America when
surveyed ask what's the way to build
wealth what's the number one way to
build wealth 75 percent of wealthy
people not your broke brother-in-law
with an opinion but wealthy people say
get out of debt and stay out of debt yep
because it gives you power over your
largest wealth building tool which is
your income